it's a landmark event in our psyche we
were always worried about terrorism
which was mainly cross-border in the
initial years we thought of it
essentially as a problem that was
effectively centered around Kashmir and
there were sporadic incidents across the
country but I think 26/11 changed a lot
of that because it made us all realize
how vulnerable we are and how soft a
target we are our Mumbai which is such a
prominent commercial city and how easy
it was for a bunch of 10 to 15 young
boys effectively to come and hold a city
to ransom for nearly four days and
occupy the attention of the whole world
just showed how how weak we are and I'm
sure Mumbai is not the only city which
can if they decide to do it in any other
European city is well I'm sure they'll
find a way because they are determined
and have believed they're really nothing
to lose how do I view the security
situation I say with a lot of
trepidation because every day we open
the newspapers we see the situation on
our western border deteriorating in a
heart sinks lower and lower every day we
don't know where that's all going to end
but we are really relying upon
Washington to help us resolve this and
look at the way India reacted did it
post 26/11 take a bunch of fighter
aircraft and bomb these camps out of
existence they could have done that I'm
sure but I think the outcome of that
would have been far worse
this is probably what those behind the
attacks were looking for and I'm glad
that our government was mature enough
not to fall into that trap
so
of like-minded citizens like myself we
filed a public interest litigation in
our High Court in Mumbai seeking
mandatory judicial reliefs for police
reform because we thought one of the
factors that would be essential for
preventing recurrence of this in future
would be a stronger security set up a
more empowered police in this case is
pending in our High Court our judiciary
has got quite interested the reason why
I did this was that India and
particularly people in urban cities have
over a period of time then called enesta
sized to some of these incidents that
were happening every day
26:11 of course was different but it was
perhaps too callous to assume that the
Mumbai spirit of Tolerance would take us
through even such incidents and we had
to do something about it
so we wanted to have positive action in
a more civilized way which was not
backward-looking but was meant towards
finding a solution and this initiative
that was taken by me and a few others
received a lot of support and I do hope
that this case goes through and
eventually something comes out of it but
people are at a superficial level
they're back to business as usual but
26/11 I think has left a deep scar on
people's minds
one thing it certainly has done is I
think every businessman in India or
somebody doing business with India
recognizing terrorist risk as now an
important business consideration I think
the cost of business going doing
business in India has gone up it
fundamentally hasn't affected people's
views on India as yet because people
believe that this is something which is
a global phenomenon terrorism is not
confined in its in its damaging impact
only to India it affects a number of
other countries as well so while at one
level it's being taken in stride it has
increased the cost of doing business no
one in the world is saying we are not
going to do business in India because it
is a high-risk target on the contrary in
fact the West went out of its way to to
demonstrate solidarity with us as
lawyers there was a important delegation
of the American Bar Association which we
hosted and on the Mumbai leg they came
to India in early January post 26/11 had
given them an option to cancel the trip
they said we're not going to do that
we're going to be in Mumbai because this
is exactly what the terrorist wants us
to do and we're not going to do that so
the West has shown extraordinary